tras varias semanas de investigación la
Policía Nacional de España ha detenido a
un hombre de 74 años por el envío de
seis cartas con material pirotécnico a
objetivos relacionados con la guerra en
Ucrania entre el 24 de noviembre y el 2
de diciembre la operación convert que
significa sobre en ucraniano se activó
al llegar la primera misiva al palacio
de la moncloa dirigida al presidente del
gobierno Pedro Sánchez le siguieron
cartas a la embajada de Ucrania en
Madrid la única que fue abierta y que
dejó heridas leves en la mano de uno de
los empleados también recibieron sobres
la delegación diplomática de Estados
Unidos el centro de satélites de la
Unión Europea en la capital Española y
una fábrica de armamento que había
manufacturado alguno de los materiales
enviados a Ucrania por el ejecutivo de
España el detenido de nacionalidad
española habría actuado en solitario y
la policía española niega que tenga
relación con grupos prorusos algo a lo
que había hecho alusión el pasado
domingo el diario estadounidense de New
York Times que señaló denominado
movimiento Imperial ruso como grupo
radical responsable de estos envíos los
agentes han terminado de registrar el
domicilio del detenido que vivía solo en
Miranda del ebro en la provincia de
Burgos al norte del país y el viernes el
sospechoso prestará declaración ante el
juez en la audiencia nacional